what are you enjoying about this journey
with three right now everything about it
yeah I'm loving it
Rihanna and ASAP Rocky's relationship
proves that love is always in style I
know thank you so much dating rumors
first sparked between Rihanna and ASAP
in 2012 during their flirty performance
together at the MTV Video Music Awards
[Music]
[Applause]
Riri later telling Vogue that her
relationship with the rapper was slow
going at first because quote people
don't get out of the friend zone very
easily with me I'm not going to let that
happen here as friends the two continue
to support each other for years in 2013
Rocky even joined Rihanna on her
diamonds World Tour for a handful of
days and in September of that year
Rihanna repaid the favor popping up in
Rocky's music video for Fashion Killa
in 2019 the two caused a stir when they
appeared on the red carpet at the
Fashion Awards together a year later in
December of 2020
ET confirmed the rapper and singer were
officially an item an Insider telling ET
quote they have always had amazing
chemistry and Rihanna release say said
and it feels natural easy and fun adding
quote she feels very comfortable around
him since they've known each other for
such a long time the source called their
connection special especially because
like Rihanna Rocky has roots and
Barbados it's where his dad's from it's
amazing and I'm honestly truly blessed
for real you know nearly a year later
Rocky opened up about the relationship
for the first time in GQ calling her
quote the love of my life and quote my
lady and in July of 2021 a separate
source told E.T that the couple is
together 24 7.
saying quote ASAP is so grateful for
Rihanna she's his biggest cheerleader
and he doesn't take her for granted it's
something he echoed to ET at the
premiere of his documentary Stockholm
syndrome which features Rihanna it was
important having that support in real
life you know and I think it just shows
that we're reveal in the dark you know
it's just how it is in real life later
that year the two were all smiles as
they made their red carpet debut as a
couple at the Met Gala a quilt has never
looked so cool
sharing their excitement with E.T oh
thank you guys for making it
ready already together
a few months later Rihanna was front and
center at complexcon rapping along to
Rocky during his set
yes Reese
fast forward to January 2022 the couple
revealed that they were expecting their
first child together with this instantly
iconic photo shoot which featured the
first of many memorable maternity
fashion moments from the Mogul you know
redefying what it means to even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend
but what should have been a totally
happy time had some trials too a few
months after their big reveal cheating
rumors surfaced around Rocky which he
and the woman called out in the tabloids
denied he was also arrested for assault
with a deadly weapon in connection to a
November shooting which is still an
active case but at the time a source
sold ET Rihanna was with her man For
Better or Worse quote there was no
question or hesitation that Rihanna
would stand by ASAP Rocky when she's in
love with someone she'll do anything for
them she loves him he's family and with
the baby on the way that rang truer than
ever how are you feeling what are you
enjoying most about this journey Korea
and Rocky were both ecstatic ahead of
the new edition's arrival I'm looking
forward to it you know this is it's all
an exciting Journey so far I'm just
taking it as it comes every week it's
something new and I'm just taking it I'm
enjoying it I'm just excited for what I
don't know yet you know everything is
new to me so you know I'm excited the
couple welcomed their first child a baby
boy into the world that may and not long
after a source confessed to E.T Rihanna
already wants more saying quote Rihanna
always dreamed of being a mom and she
takes a lot of pride in it she would
love to have more children with ASAP in
the future
foreign
and in December the Navy finally got its
first glimpse of ree's son whose name
was still a mystery that's amazing he's
a happy baby
oh
my God the morning's just like seeing
his morning face and you know like
seeing a baby with like little bags and
waking up and they're just like startled
they're trying to figure out where they
at is the cutest is my favorite part of
the day so what's next for Rocky and
Reed we'll just have to wait and see you
know I always thought doing kid stuff
would be like
cliche and obviously the the obvious
thing to do when you have nothing when
you have a baby right it's like the
obvious Next Step but
when I went shopping
that's what I realized like okay maybe I
need to start making the stuff that I
want my kids to wear because it's hard
it's hard
[Music]